[Music]
hello all right hello
why did I press the record button you
chose to it was an act of pure Free Will
no no we have to we got it there was
this shocking like neuro scientist thing
where they uh they have their brain
wired up and then they tell them to
press a button
but the brain decides to press the
button before the Consciousness decides
to press the button yeah cut your
Consciousness justifies after the fact
the fact that you intended to press the
button
yeah I forget how that experiment went
maybe I should have looked it up I
remember hearing about that it was kind
of like
the experimenters or whatever were able
to predict the choice that the person
was going to make based on their brain
patterns before the person knew when
they like which was kind of seen as
evidence for determinism I guess
yeah it's like the decisions already
made
the muscular motility happens before the
conscious decision part of it decides
something like that
yeah you're you made the decision before
you're aware of it
yo just before we like get into the
topic just like kind of in a side I
noticed on Twitter I don't know if this
has happened to any of you but randomly
like I responded to something about like
Canadian politics like a couple days ago
like some inside baseball Canadian
politics like thing from about like Paul
Martin and I like I responded to this
one guy and
it's been retweeted like that my
response
so weird like this tweet in particular
by a bunch of like cam girls like
Oh weird like it's all like
it's like Evelyn and then her bio is
like hot girls waiting for you here and
then it's like they're all have the same
bio and it's just like
obviously it's some kind of scam like
they probably just like retweet like
what they perceive as men's accounts to
like try to get them but it's just so
weird why would you pick like my
responses about like the NDP not having
a majority in order to like give the
Liberals enough to like prevent Stephen
Harper from forming his first minority
it's like a super nerdy like Canadian
politics tweet and it's just so weird
that that's the tweet
that cam girls chose to I guess it's cam
girls I don't even know what it is but
anyway yeah I wonder I wonder if some of
those accounts are like bot accounts yo
I'm sure they I'm sure they are so so
there must be something like in the
algorithm that like these I guess you're
right they're probably like bot accounts
that are just like for these sites or
whatever and then they there must be
some keyword in my tweet or something
who knows it's bizarre anyway Paul
Martin it's probably because
politics perverts politics perverts are
especially horny so yeah exactly so like
maybe Canadian politics nerds are like
more likely to be staffers who like you
know cheat on their wives who knows it's
so weird hey only only fans isn't
cheating yeah yeah whatever
I mean depending on your relationship
yeah sure sure all right we're doing
freedom and Twitter speaking of Twitter
completely unusable but I do want to
search it
because we're talking about freedom and
I wanted to search
what it what is being uh said about
Freedom just in passing so I did
something you should never do which is
sort by latest
and there's there's the normal freedom
and democracy freedom of speech that
kind of stuff which is what I was
expecting but
the thing that is being pumped with the
word freedom in it is this uh q and not
well I guess it's Downstream from Q Anon
but the movie
sound of freedom
oh sound you heard of this no I haven't
actually oh it's a it's the guy who
played Jesus
in the Mel Gibson Jesus movie oh nice
and I think he's a bit q-pilled but he's
saving children from sex trafficking
like uh taken taken styled oh my God so
it's like it's straight up like a it's
like a conservative wet dream movie of
like
saving people from like a pedophile ring
he leaves his uh his job at the state
department I haven't seen obviously but
this oh it's Jim Jim Caviezel yeah it's
based on a true story about the U.S
Homeland Security agent who did some
pedophilia investigation oh so it's a
real story Tim Ballard is a real person
he's he's the yeah I'm looking at the
accurate section accuracy section on
Wikipedia yeah it's about his
involvement with something called
operation Underground Railroad
um but it was but apparently like
embellished a lot of details
and a lot of people are apparently
questioning the validity or the accuracy
of the movie so there's there's some
kind of embellishment oh man I totally
thought I'm like a little disappointed
that it's actually maybe based on
something real I thought it was just
like totally from the conservative like
wet dream like Fantasyland
well I'm sure it's that too it made 45
million dollars
on like a 10 million or low low million
dollar budget which was Jim Caviezel one
of those actors who's actually like I
didn't know that he was um like
conservative pills
well he played Jesus you got it yeah but
I I I remember like I feel like I have a
vague memory of looking into
whether he was he actually was like very
religious and I I have like a memory of
me finding out that he wasn't but now
I'm looking at the Wikipedia and you're
right it says he's a devote cat devout
Catholic so
yeah yeah well also this studio that's
Distributing it I checked I'm looking at
this they're Mormons so I didn't know
this but the Mormons are queued up too
well yeah and you're right it does say
that it does say that in 2021 cavizel
endorsed some elements of Q Anon Theory
I mean it's it's not super surprising
the traditional reli the traditional
Christian mythology just isn't enough
anymore so you need to uh put the the
white hat stuff in there to make it
remember when all that remember when all
that Scientology stuff started kind of
exploding in the Arts and suddenly it
seemed like half of the actors in
Hollywood were [__] scientologists
like you know the weird ones like Tom
Cruise and Travolta obviously but then
like so many others were they just they
just were involved and then it later
came out that like there's a lot of
coercion and and really kind of
underhanded [__] and that Scientology is
an extremely like persecutory kind of
religion you say anything bad about them
and they'll [__] your life up yeah
they're very ambitious
yeah and they keep documents and they
threaten to expose [__] about you and
like it's classic cult [__] right and
public figures are the ones they want
right because that's the most exposure
they get and I guess in this day and age
it's also creating like [__] social
media storms is another strategy now but
yeah these it's not surprising to me
that some of these actors would then be
going for a q Anon which is like what's
the differences it's Scientology but
it's but like disaggregated and
decentralized and more online
yeah if you are already a Mormon or some
kind of Evangelical you're primed to
believe in some pretty paranoia
fantasies already that you're the main
character and I'm manekean Cosmic war or
every convenience store is full of
demons so it makes sense that the new
Jesus is wearing a bulletproof vest and
uh taking on the establishment of
pedophile vampires which is way more
exciting than some Iron Age
Jew dying for your porn addiction
yeah you know it's it's funny like
speaking of just kind of conservative
fantasies like uh when I was consuming
kind of for fun out of curiosity some of
these red pill like YouTube channels or
whatever I remember like one of the
things that they would always talk about
which just struck me as a hilarious
right-wing fantasy about basically like
why
the man needs to be the protector or
whatever and the man needs to be it's
like their scenarios were always the
most ridiculous like well like if my
girlfriend if like some kidnappers come
out of nowhere it's like I need to be
able to defend her and it's just like
it's like what it's the most absurd
things it's like I need to be trained in
like Krav Maga like Israeli military
stuff so that I can defend my woman from
like kidnappers and pedophiles or
whatever and it's it's just like the
most like Fantasyland reason for it and
it's like that would always be the thing
that they would respond to
and it's like dude is that the best
reason like is that is that like the
most
like practical reason to be in shape
right and like that would be the [__]
that they would talk about or like as
long as as long as they're in shape this
is taken is the same thing
like what if what if my daughter goes to
Croatia and gets like stolen exactly and
speaking of Liam Neeson was he even inch
that much in shape in those movies like
you have a certain set of skills are
there three uh Takens or more the first
one I think I think there's at least two
I don't know if there's three I mean
speaking of Liam Neeson he totally
trafficked a kid in
Star Wars episode one
oh yeah he literally bought him you know
what star Star Wars episode one this
should be this should be the analogy for
why child trafficking is wrong because
some of these freedom
some Elites well did they did they some
Elites come out of the sky in a very in
a very expensive ship they buy a child
based on his mediclaurean count I.E his
good adrenochrome
and then what happens to the mother
cells because she has no other options
so she agrees to it and then he gets
passed from Elite to Elite from the
Jedi's to the queen to the emperor and
who knows what's going on there off
screen and then you know this is uh the
birth of a great evil throughout the
Galaxy caused by child trafficking you
know let's yeah
you know you have a slave market that
functions on money and you have a legit
Market that functions on money you can
use money to free slaves which is what
uh Qui-Gon Jinn supposedly does he buys
them from watto and gives them his
freedom but he doesn't actually buy his
freedom because he forces him to go to a
boarding school where he's not allowed
to leave or feel anything anymore yeah
exactly yeah and then yeah subjected to
all kinds of shoes Darth Vader because
we forget that that is Darth Vader too
because
anyways these these these kinds of
activities would would supposedly fall
under the the uh under the Ambit of
Freedom right like the freedom of
economic activity the freedom of
religion freedom of those kinds of
choices right so very nice segue Eric
that was great what like what we think
of dealing with freedom in that way is
like okay now we gotta put what's the
limits to Freedom now that's that would
be like the question that emerges but
then you're in this horrible
contradiction now because it's like well
you're either free or you're not free
you're not a little bit free just like
someone's not a little bit pregnant
they're either pregnant or not pregnant
yeah a circle with a hole and it's not a
circle you either got a circle or you
don't but yeah this is uh we kind of
just said let's put an object on the
table and we picked one of the most
General and overcoated possible Concepts
so if it's Freedom versus determinism
we're gonna get to uh phenomenology
which I think makes a pretty good case
that we are free in a very limited sense
but why don't we go through some of the
ideological
codes
of the concept of freedom and
justification of it that we have like
what what do most people mean when they
say we need Freedom or we would want so
like politically or like just in our
life if you search it on Twitter like I
tried to before I got sidetracked by
the sound of freedom I mean I mean you
can you can slice it up like uh laws of
nature right that apply to non-human
things and they are not free they have
no free will they're just determined
they bounce off of each other we can
figure out those laws and then on the
side of politics that's where humans are
free we're free because we're rational
it's like the the the origin of the
liberal arts kind of thing right the
origin of the liberal arts is not
liberal doesn't mean political it's in
opposition to the mechanical Arts right
so the liberal arts literally freeze
your mind from drudgery because you're
doing mathematics and and music and and
poetry
rather than doing menial work
I love how I okay I asked what most
people
mean when they use the word freedom and
your response your good good response
but I don't think most people
immediately think of the context of the
Renaissance University curriculum when
using the word Freedom what I was trying
to get I watched a few clips of the NATO
conference right and I even in the few
clips
Freedom was mentioned multiple times as
sort of a justification of
NATO's existence and then part of NATO's
mission is pursuing Freedom so that's a
little bit more what I was trying to get
at I mean I wonder if at that level what
people mostly mean is like uh like
like maybe it's more easily identified
through like in a negative conception
right so it's like an absence of
structures of domination or like an
absence of direct interference so like
there is
you know there there is that kind of
which is kind of liberal Freedom right
which is negative Freedom just like not
having obstacles that overtly interfere
with you whereas
you know some kind of more positive
account of Freedom which I find like I
guess spookier in the sense that it's a
bit more
unclear what it is is like some some
kind of positive account of like
giving yourself laws that you that you
follow like kind of like in the kantian
sense I would say Kant
gives the most
I think crazy but like strong
endorsement of something we would call
philosophically Freedom but probably at
that like more common sense level people
probably just mean the negative version
right just like not having these things
that get in your way but when we go from
when we go from the sort of original
concept of Freedom let's say as like
residing in in in what distinguishes
humans from the rest of the universe
which is like I don't know cognitive
ability reasoning capacity and for for
cons you know there's nothing in the
object which the Mind hasn't put there
and on the side of nature you have these
unfree kind of law determined and
necessary laws that things follow
they're not free and then the next stage
is kind of Marxism
where
freedom is kind of redefined
in in two ways and one of them is um one
of them is is the freeing of people from
their ownership over the means of
production
which is which is um what capitalist
freedom is about right it's about you
know
getting ownership out of the hands of
people
which the United States has an extremely
extensive history of doing I just was
reading about the Congo today and the
Cobalt mining industry which has been
completely expropriated from the
Congolese people
um and then the second aspect of marxist
freedom is the freedom to sell your
labor on the market so that they claim
oh you're free because you can choose to
freely dispose of your labor
to to which the responses should
sarcastically be like like oh yeah I
love to have to work for a living right
that's great yeah I'm free to I'm free
to either not be able to feed myself and
my family or I'm free to go sell my
labor to some shitty employer
but yeah that's the the kind of that's
kind of a negative conception for
Freedom right freedom from ownership of
the means of production so you become a
kind of free-floating agent and then
Freedom you can be then you know
assimilated into a labor pool where
you're quote unquote free to dispose of
your own personal labor as you choose
which is
very much the opposite there's also like
I think there can be a weird fantasy of
like being free on the Marxist side I
think where no matter what you're gonna
have to work right like there's things
you just have to do in your life that
require your attention that require
labor that are annoying like as things
as banal is doing your laundry cleaning
your house like there's just [__] that
you have to do
um getting food I mean even if you're
thinking about some kind of like a narco
primitivist Society there's like a bunch
of [__] to do there's like a bunch of
work that you got to do right like you
can't get away from that
well that's why the question of social
freedom is more like um like do you have
power to make other people do that [__]
for you or do you have to do that [__]
yourself and make money and survive on
the time right like so that's there's a
sliding scale there when you're at the
you're in the lower classes right you're
much less free yeah of course for the
upper class and the lower classes
they're humans they have to do those
things but there's a big difference in
the way they get done
right I suppose most people aren't like
a lot of wealthy people don't even need
to raise their own [__] kids right
but the payout the thing that you get so
you don't have to pay attention to that
stuff
not the freedom of production we sell
that get rid of that and then we get the
freedom of consumption to make up for it
so we are free we have a free market but
freedom in that sense is just a
marketing slogan because the consumer
gets to
perceive is distinctive behaviors as
freedom but it's a choice to choose
between
you know two brands of bread or two
brands of cereal or two brands of milk
two brands of car kind of poor
substitute for Freedom called variety or
selection on those different [__]
brands
yeah I mean I think that the the
distinction can come when thinking about
with the West versus China right like
you have the difference between maybe
liberal freedom or well or even just
like freedom is non-domination or
something like that right like that
there's more potential for a kind of
arbitrary interference in your freedom
yeah but the freedom that I'm talking
about in terms of consumption is
compelled upon you because that's the
only one that there's left
I'm not I'm saying about the perception
of China I don't know anything about
actual China but I mean it exists if you
hear anyone speak about China it's oh
they have social credit whatever and we
don't so we're free and just putting
aside whether that's correct or not I
don't know if I assume it's not because
you know try buying a house here without
our version of social credit which is uh
you know your bank credit score but
anyway I just mean to say that freedom
in this context is used as a designation
of us a free society as opposed to them
they the unfree societies I mean this
that's a there's a fundamental point to
be made that you you cannot tell like as
an individual you cannot tell how free
you are until you start comparing
yourself and your life with other people
in other places right you can't you
can't know what freedom is until you
have a society in which you live and
have some idea about right and so you
know the fact that we do you know we
don't know what goes on in China but we
assume that they're less free and then
we use that as a comparison or we
no I certainly don't know what goes on
in in in politics in in South America
and Central America but
but I mean I assume yeah okay people
come here I've I've had roommates
immigrant roommates or or foreign
students and and they say yeah yeah it's
great here back home you know you could
get in trouble for this or that
and it's like yeah you guys are having
no economic opportunities right there's
just like you know more I'm like well
well so is there some absolute scale of
freedom because then the concept of
freedom in relation to determinacy
they're complete opposites right they
get they cannot coexist right absolute
freedom and necessity
you can't you can't have both but we
kind of have this way of reconciling
them thinking of like yeah we're free
but then there are constraints we're
born free and then there are the
constraints are all external to
ourselves or something like that which I
think is a bit simplistic but that seems
to be the general you know so I find
less external constraints to my freedom
here than I do elsewhere well well maybe
those constraints are hidden right like
like buying a house I'm not free to buy
a house anymore maybe that's my fault
for not making enough money but it's
certainly not my fault that they cost a
fraction of what they did 20 years ago
right so I'm less free just as a result
of these natural laws of the marketplace
and inflation there's a lot of reasons
to be really distrustful of the word
freedom because it's the most
ideologically loaded concept for what it
you for what it's used to justify but
even the Judgment of
I am free as opposed to someone else
therefore I should be like happy with
what I have that's not a judgment made
in Freedom it's a judgment made in in
basically media projections of places
and people that I've never experienced
in my life but I believe that
by default because that is my experience
of you know China for example
um and that's not a free judgment either
that's a judgment made based on an
apparatus that has decided for me what I
can consume just like they can decide
what I can consume in the grocery store
my understanding of my own freedom is
determined by what I relatively rate
other versions of Freedom that are
usually for you know jingoist reasons
said to not apply in other places that
do apply to me one last
thing about freedom to bring up is
probably
um relates to Nato and any other kind of
political decision-making processes is
well deliberation right we tend to look
at at a decision the outcome of a
decision-making process how like with
the freedom of the deliberations that's
that's one thing you look at right like
what are the what are the factors and
the motivations
how free how freely are the uh parties
really in negotiating and and how is the
outcome you look at like inputs and
outcomes and then you can kind of look
at the process itself which is
which is kind of backwards according to
Ponte right we we make the decision and
then it's afterwards that we kind of
contemplate whether or not it was a free
decision or not so we don't we're not
aware of our freedom in the moment of
making a decision it's not it's not a
factor we it's only something that comes
afterwards so you get it backwards and
you say like a decision was made freely
now the decision was made just as we
were saying in the beginning it's
already made and then only afterwards we
we think about whether it was free or
not but again we tend to sort of get
that flipped well freedom is actually a
metaphysical term because you're
deciding
which causes have effects and where the
causality comes from and I think this
naive the humanist view the naive view
of uh freedom is that inside you
somewhere
there is and this is what I wanted to
get your opinion with the phenomenology
because inside you somewhere there's an
open space that is causal
and long for a long time it's been
called the soul and then sometimes it's
called the reason and it's called it's
this capacity to act to produce
causality
uh without external interference so if
we're making our decisions and we
believe them to be free that doesn't
really matter it matters if this causal
apparatus inside a person is acting on
its own or whether it is uh being
influenced by external causation of
which it's unaware
so then we're looking at the conditions
we're looking at like the the kind of
conditions under which the decision is
made yeah I mean the conditions of
freedom in other words I mean the way
that I see it is like I think that what
marilopanti and others and actually this
relates back to the episode we did two
weeks ago with that paper that you
really hated uh pills like that there's
not really such thing as like being
determined and determining like I think
it's just one phenomena that like there
is a sense in which there's a decision
but it's always in the background of
other factors it's conditioned freedom
is I think one of the sections in
Maryland Ponte where he talks about it
and you know even when we with our more
popular like or discussion of what the
popular rhetoric around freedom is it's
like I think all of that rhetoric gets
it kind of wrong like even when talking
about how
oh like we're not free because of these
social structures which to some extent
yeah that's true but there's another
extent in which like there's not really
such a thing as like a free
a Freer State like I think even just
talking in terms of freedom is almost
like the wrong
the wrong way of looking at those social
problems it's more like yeah wait if I
can cut you off sorry if I can cut you
off because I can tell you're moving in
the other direction so to summarize so
far we've been speaking of the liberal
conception of Freedom which is to say
you're free to live your life
without external impingement usually
from the state or The Sovereign so
freedom is freedom to act without
external constraint causal efficacies on
your side and the state limits it as
little as possible hopefully it's
focused on the individual it's focused
on the individual the social context is
a problem
in Merlo Ponte he says you cannot have
freedom without social context I.E
inter-subjectivity
it's not individualistic like liberal
freedom is it's like your individual
Freedom being either impinged on or
enabled by government Society whatever
right that's it's individualistic and
then to be very simplistic Marx is the
opposite it's social it's all on the
social it has nothing to do with the
individual because
worker and capitalists are just roles
they're not referring to people
and so social freedom is about that
social conditions that which enables the
individual to be free it's not a problem
it's the source so we have these two
opposites and they're irreconcilable I
mean I take issue with that like
definition of liberal like I think it's
a bit that's like a little bit of a
simplistic but I mean that's fair enough
I think like oh my both focus on both
they're both they're both overly simple
I mean I think yeah sure like like it is
more focused on the individual but it's
complicated because I mean liberal
theory is really just a theory of
government and it's just like all we can
have are like
to make a government maximally liberal
it's to like reduce the number of direct
impingements from some kind of
centralized Authority that's liberal the
freedom from the government perspective
but I don't know if I think a lot of
people take that and then think that
liberals have a really like robust
metaphysical commitment to some kind of
individualism when I think really
they're just mostly talking about
government and kind of stay neutral or
don't say that much about
uh like the metaphysical question
couldn't you still say though that it's
just Downstream from like sure you could
it's it's Downstream from like a a
hobbsian view of what the government is
the the subject is created by The
Sovereign as an inverse yeah like in a
way Hobbes is like yeah Freedom opposite
from Rousseau I mean Rousseau is a
little more complicated because I would
say he has a what's what some in the
literature call a republican notion of
Freedom which is like freedom is
self-determination it's like a positive
account to Freedom which is kind of what
he does in the social contract as like
it's not just that a government doesn't
uh put constraints in front of you it's
that there's actually a positive
mechanism that lets people come together
and actually like self-determine
and if we shift to uh phenomenology then
from from a governmental subject versus
Authority type of
framing of this problem which is I think
we've all agreed not a very good framing
merlu Ponte if I could summarize this in
like two sentences
no matter where you are who you are what
governmental system you live under even
if you're a slave you have a sort of
Freedom by virtue of being conscious
because as a human
in time with a sort of phenomenological
Consciousness you are always in the
midst of projects
and you're not free to not pick a
project and a project in this sense
means
a project means to throw forward you're
always
Imaging the future and then getting
towards a future and you can start a
project and quit it but then you're
already starting a new project even if
the project is not overthrow the
government but I need to go to the
fridge to get a glass of milk that would
be a project that you comport yourself
towards and just by the nature of time
and the nature of our experience of time
in those types of things you're not free
to not be free or compelled
no matter what the constraints are you
are on you even if you're in a cell
in a prison cell you still comport
yourselves towards certain futures
though that sounds really existentialist
uh it sounds like uh starts starts
existentialist Freedom until you bring
in the world into it because the world
is you're negotiating with the world
here which is like here's a bed it's a
sort of a good thing to lay down on
while you're in prison here I think one
of the things that's a bit tricky about
this chapter and when I was reading it
again is he does that typical thing that
he always does in this book which is
he'll like he'll he'll he'll say of you
and then like later he'll be like oh but
that's not actually what I'm like
talking about and I feel like the first
parts of this chapter he is I think kind
of talking about the sartrian view in a
few places and then shifts back and
forth and they're similar so like I
don't think it's straight up what you
were saying there is wrong but I think
um he does want to talk more about the
situation the kind of existential
situation on the way that that frames
your possibilities for freedom but he's
still at the same time wants to say
you're still free it's like the the sell
example is a good one I think sart
actually has the same example I wanna in
somewhere where he says you know you can
you can be free to sit there and take it
or you can be free to
um you know scream and Bash on the bars
or whatever but um there's also a part I
liked it in the marilloponte where he he
talks about
um you know uh if I am ugly then I have
a choice to either be an outcast or to
condemn others that is I am left free
between masochism and sad at sadism but
I am not free to ignore others right
meaning that's the inner subjective part
right like the weight of the inner
subjective
does for like kind of force you to react
to that thing but it's like how you
react is free but that situation you
can't get out of that situation and I
take that the reason I was actually
looking at this for my dissertation is
because um
I'm looking at a lot of habit and the
way that habit habituation interferes
with the possibilities for radical
politics right as some of you might know
and uh
and I think that fruit like it was
important to me to like go and revisit
the freedom chapter because it's like I
need to talk about okay well what does
he say is he like fully like am I just
saying there's no hope uh or something
like that but no no I mean I think he
talks a lot about first of all that
framing things is free and unfree
doesn't really make sense anyway
but also that like yeah like you you are
free insofar as you're in a situation
but that situation is structured by a
lot of things that you can't get away
from right so can't get away from the
social can't get away from habituation
right that's something like you have a
habituation it's part of your actual
situation your kind of existential
situation and then there's a series of
ways in which you can react to that
ground and one thing that I really like
about what he does in this chapter is
sort of say well look like even talking
about freedom without a situation makes
no sense right so it's like oh it sounds
like it's a constraint on your freedom
but it's like you actually need a ground
to make a decision on and that ground is
your existential situation which can
feel like a constraint but it's also a
condition of possibility to even do
anything so he I think he's trying to
dissolve that dichotomy between
determinism and freedom
and he's still using the language as if
they're both separate things
But ultimately he's kind of saying
they're one interconnected system right
like you're there's an agency there's a
social and then there is like the
upsurge of a decision that can be made
that can only be made in that context of
the situation of the situation if that
makes sense but that that's how I was
reading it and I guess I don't know if
that's I don't know if that's
inconsistent with anything you said
pills like directly
but but I do think that one of the
differences between start and
marilloponte as I take them to do is I
think marilopanti is paying a lot more
attention to those things to the way
that the actual existential situation is
structured
that you can't avoid and I think maybe
start
like wants to lean more into well no
like you you know there is some kind of
transcendental ego that can that can you
know rise out of it more easily or
something
start almost well I haven't read them in
a really long time so I want to put my
foot in my mouth but he seems to think
that any situation is constrained and
the opposite of freedom and somehow the
ego ideal can liberate itself from that
through thought
and you're right like merlu Ponte is
saying there is a universality to
consciousness
but that Consciousness is not free from
restraint it's free because there are
restraints
exactly the only way the only way you
can have a possibility is by having a
whole bunch of I don't know inclinations
or habits or a situation whether it's a
prison cell or a Marketplace uh you have
to have projects yeah exactly and it's
also important to note that those are
not conscious I said conscious a few
times but this is not rational For
Thought Consciousness it belongs to your
state of body Consciousness knowing
knowing how to do stuff yes I I can say
one thing about this too because I did
pick up a little bit and I think here
you can correct me if I'm wrong but when
it when when uh pontesa's Freedom
requires a field
right what I think what I think he's
doing is he's he's removing you know
social we say social constraint or or
what enabling social conditions he's
just going to call it a field right and
freedom cannot exist without a field so
starts can starts conception of Freedom
that you just described is starting with
an existential situation this is this is
sin I think it's it's the centrifi
centrifugal freedom
uh where Freedom kind of radiates
outwards from us we decide what we are
and what our projects are we decide
these things and then freedom is
centrifugal from there social
constraints are beaten down right but
but for Ponte um this is this is only
partial freedom is both centrifugal and
centripetal meaning it flows both
outwards into a field and inwards
towards you from a field right so when
he says you know sart himself observes
dreaming is incompatible with freedom
because in the realm of imagination we
have no sooner taken a certain
significance as our goal then we are
already than we already believe that we
have intuitively brought it into being
in short because there's no obstacle and
nothing to do so there's no freedom in
dreaming because there's no doing in
dreaming right in order to have freedom
we must have doing but then he says a
few lines later but we can see beneath
these noisy debates and the fruitless
efforts to construct ourselves the tacit
decisions whereby we have marked out
around ourselves the field of
possibility right like a world is given
to you as a kind of whole right you
can't sort of separate yourself from it
ahead of time and assign freedom to
yourself and a simpler maybe a simpler
way to say it is just that the world
elicits your freedom it pulls you into
projects you don't project yourself
maybe I said that to satrian earlier
yeah I mean I think I think you can I
think both are true the world pulls on
you
like if you have a prison cell there's a
space in there there's a bed there's I
don't know whatever you got into prison
cell but those things elicit
projects just to keep yourself busy too
I mean maybe that's too radical of an
example like you know take something
more like I mean I think habituation is
a good example right because your
habituation is pulling you in something
or like laziness whatever that means
right like you don't want to work out
today and it's like okay that's the pull
it's soliciting you to [__] sit on
the couch and and play video games
um but then freedom is to be like no I'm
gonna exercise right it's like but it's
only because there's that ground of the
pull right you have a solicitation
and and then you you can be free and
it's still freedom to be like yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna be a lazy bum right like
that's there's still a sense in which
that's freedom
um but it's like that is part of it
right like you can't you can't be like
free of those pulls of those
solicitations
um and to think that that's Freedom that
wouldn't make any sense it's it's like
it's only because you have all those
things that then you can you can do
otherwise or you or you can do something
you can react to it and you're making a
choice by doing that and some choices
are easier to make than other ones right
it's it's harder to be like no I'm gonna
go [__] do an hour workout instead of
sitting on the couch playing I'm playing
Demon Souls right now on PS5 and it's
Excellence
um so and I would rather be I think I I
think I might have screwed up with some
people saying um Consciousness because
body Consciousness it's not the same as
the division that we have in other
discourses between conscious and
unconscious because the sound of it
Consciousness implies like a thinking
about thinking and the whole point is
that none of this stuff happens via
thinking so the UN the not doing is
an expression of the freedom but also
they're not doing is the expression of
Freedom the decision part of it doesn't
have to be made with in a reflective
State when you're thinking like how
should I use my time today it's more
that you are free to both be pulled and
to resist polls to have habits and to
break habits
yeah exactly and it's interesting I
think he even has an example of like
someone who has an inferiority complex
right and he's like you know
um you know you might have built your
life uh on an inferiority complex right
reinforcing them for 20 years and then
he says it's not likely that you'll
change he says at one point right but
but that doesn't mean that there's not a
sphere of Freedom there that exists it's
just that it's just being like upfront
and realistic about the fact that there
are these things that sediment right
into you that that you have to reckon
with and without those things it's like
you wouldn't be an existential being you
wouldn't be anything so therefore like
the question of some Freedom that's more
pure than this I think what he's trying
to show is like
the idea of some Freedom that that is
like free of these things
doesn't make any sense that that like
that it's almost like a you know what
reminds me you know to connect it to
sort of popular analytic philosophy I
remember reading this really short
little kind of simple book on the
philosophy of the analytic debate of
Freedom versus determinism and I
remember one of the thoughts that the
author had or one of the arguments the
author makes is he's like
okay like let's try to get clear on what
it is we're talking about when we say
freedom and then he says okay like
imagine that you before a thought popped
into your head you had to decide that
that thought was going to pop into your
head it's like was that something that
we would want
it's like he's like no that sounds
horrible right that wouldn't be so okay
so surely the thing that we're targeting
is in some kind of crazy Pure Freedom
where you're deciding about literally
everything there's obviously things that
happen and that reminds me actually a
lot of
um one of the quotes from marilopanti
that I kind of uh that I kind of marked
off it's like he says something like um
yeah he says everything happens as if
prior to our judgments and our freedom
someone were allocating such and such a
sense to such and such a given
constellation right so what he's saying
is like prior to us even thinking about
something it does feel like there is a
sense to things which is right right
it's like there is a sense to things
um that doesn't mean that there's not
some way in which that can be ambiguous
and that can be acted on in a different
way but there is something that is kind
of like not really a choice that just
like shows up
as if some other force is giving it to
us right like some sense of yes there is
there's so sense to things yeah so so
it's like this idea that like Freedom
could exist in some pure sense like
maybe the way that Kant wanted which is
[__] insane like you know pure
practical reason right that is that's
literally what Constable is right in in
the in the groundwork of the metaphysics
it's defined a like practical reason
reason that we can use to act on things
that is free from any constraints or
free from any influence in the world
right that's like only mental which is
[__] insane
um
so like and I think that in some ways
this the phenomenology perception is
definitely an attack on that kind of
kantian freedom yeah yeah he says the
the kantian idea which what I mentioned
earlier fines and things only what the
mind has put there what Consciousness
has put into them which is one side
right that's the centrifugal side right
but if we Define ourselves and this is
seems to be what the way it goes we
Define ourselves I said sense giving
earlier
if we Define ourselves as as the
universal sense giving but by our powers
of universal sense giving right then you
think think of any project right you
think of think again in phenomenological
terms of being in the world and being
involved in projects right a rock could
be an obstacle if your project is hiking
through the woods or a rock could be a
useful tool if you have if you're if
it's windy and you need a paper weight
right like like there's no there's no
absolute constraints or
instrumentalizing of of anything we we
give it those senses okay yeah yeah it's
centrifugal but then think of um
if you've ever heard of the term
affordances from uh Gibson right of the
the world also has a sense of itself
there's there's a kind of sense that
emerges from the world which is kind of
given to us that doesn't sort of
originate with us and we can that's
that's not a metaphysical claim because
we can distinguish that within
experience I can distinguish things that
reduce to my experience of them and I
can and I can distinguish between
objects of my experience that don't
reduce to my experience of them there
you go there's the the difference
between a thing
and an object which may also um
or may not also be a thing but we don't
know there's no markings on our objects
of our perception that tell us whether
they originate from us or outside of us
just as when you look you think you see
a continuous field of vision but really
there's two big donut holes in the
middle of both your eyes called your
optic nerves right is that the Illusion
part and everything else is the real
part no because there's no that's even
that distinction is inferred from within
our experience of things of of failure
of surprise of of of learning something
we didn't know before or and then being
able to do something more easily with
that knowledge we understand there are
sources outside of ourselves of meaning
as well they can be centripetal that's
what it gives the example of the
mountain climbing right like I look at
the mountain and I proportion it to my
own body and I see that I can't you know
take it in a single stride right I can
go get a glass of milk from the fridge
that's something that doesn't challenge
my bodily proportionality to the world
but a mountain does and a mountain
present and so but is is that coming
from us of course we're assigning that
in proportional that massive extension
to the mountain of course we're
assigning that in a cognitive judgment
but is there not some role of the thing
in that meaning as well the affordance
right it affords you know why do I climb
a mountain because it's there it affords
the possibility there's a certain kind
of meaning outside and we shouldn't go
into a phenomenological analysis with an
a priori kind of determination to
distinguish between things that
originate in humans and things that
originate outside of them kind of thing
right
yeah exactly he says actually um
really short like kind of two sentences
he says um the world is always already
constituted but also never completely
constituted in the first relation we are
solicited in the second we are open to
an Infinity of possibilities right and I
think like that grabs those two things
and I would say like what's it what I
like about that quote too is you know
from my own my own work that I'm doing
I think that
too many like people who try to take
kind of insights from Continental
thought they I think they spend too much
time on that second part right we are
open to an Infinity of possibilities but
don't take up the really serious
implications of the first part which is
we are solicited by the world right like
so anyway yeah what this kind of boils
down to is that almost all people are
not free almost all of the time
we're speaking here
I mean this whole book is about an
exceptional state where you can sit back
and reflect on your freedom which is why
it comes at the end of a 600 page book
yeah
and despite the fact that we're not
really aware of our freedom almost all
of the time all of the meaning that's
experienced
in life the meaning of life you could
say comes from that little bit of
Freedom that we have and it gives these
examples if you're in a in a
automatic State what better example is
there than say sleepwalking right and
yet you could still you you are your
body is still you know proportioning out
its own actions to a world without your
conscious involvement people have gotten
into cars and driven successfully
if you can call it that on sleepwalking
some ambulatory kinds of experiences
like that are unconscious and and again
sart would say I well I don't know what
he would say about sleep walking we know
what he would say about dreaming though
where you're not free because there's no
obstacles there uh well even when you're
sleepwalking there are obstacles so even
if you're in an automatic State it's
still there's still a question of of
this Freedom right like I'm sure a
sleepwalker is is somewhat aware of of
uh what it can and cannot do I mean
Freedom isn't simply a conscious thing
either your your projects which are
proportioned to your goals and desires
and whatever those the the world and and
your social media gives those projects
meaning like my simplistic take is that
for you know sart our projects give the
mean the world meaning but for Ponte
says yes but also the world gives our
projects meaning so we did talk about
this in another episode but I thought
it's worth kind of mentioning
to The Listener especially if maybe the
listener didn't hear this previous
episode but the freedom chapter is also
the part of the book where marilopanti
does talk about Revolution which is kind
of fun right and I believe we read that
fragment at the time I want to say pills
you were released your video about the
CIA maybe and radical Theory and I feel
like you were on that Arc where you were
like look at how like you know there's
no such thing as you know like thinking
about some Revolution then doing it and
marilopanti kind of exactly says that
here right he's sort of like class
Consciousness it doesn't come around and
he really takes a shot at theorists
right he's kind of like you know class
Consciousness isn't helped by theorists
like who come in and theorize it it's
like you have to be a concrete agent in
a situation where you see you're like oh
wow like that other person lost their
job or that other person does can't get
food on the table and I can't either and
it's like and class Consciousness comes
from actually it relates to what Eric
was just saying about comparison and
inner subjectivity right it's like you
find yourself in a situation with others
where you all realize you're like holy
[__] I'm being starved by this Factory
I'm being like exploited it's not
because you have some kind of moralistic
ideas
in your head it's because the world
around you is changing in such a way
that it solicits you to
kind of spontaneously be like well we
gotta [__] do some different [__]
here you know I think he says um at one
point he's like at most we can say the
revolution is at the end of the paths
they have taken and is in their projects
in the form of a things must change
which eat each concretely experiences in
his own difficulties and at the basis of
his particular unquestioned beliefs so
it's like you know it happens because
you have a a visceral concrete
experience it's not because you're a
persuaded that you know capitalism must
be brought down or something right it
has to be a concrete which also I think
explains why revolutions don't happen in
a lot of industrialized places because
there's not enough visceral stuff that
leads to class Consciousness it's not
because we don't have persuasive enough
theorists but I mean we talked about
this in the other episode but I just
thought it's mentioning worth mentioning
that's in this chapter the freedom
chapter yeah yeah his he was he had
difficulty reconciling uh sart's Marxism
with with sart's kind of existentialism
because of this sort of focus on the
individual and and self-definition and
and uh the the choosing projects to be
involved in
um he saw that as kind of incompatible
with the the Marxist social analysis
side yeah where where you become aware
that yeah there's a group of people like
me who are being exploited and then
there's another group of people and
unlike us who are exploiters right and
then you then there's you have start to
have the inklings of a class
Consciousness there
which is very different to say it's a
saying um to saying that I choose my
projects for myself and and this Factory
is a constraint on my self-realization
like that's a very different kind of
wave of those are like two almost uh
almost two double vision going on there
yeah he says a class is coming into
being and we co we call it a situation
or we call a situation revolutionary
when the objectively existing connection
between the segments of the proletariat
that is those connections that an
absolute Observer would ultimately
recognize between them is finally
experienced in the perception of a
common obstacle to each one's existence
there is never a need for a
representation of the Revolution to
arise
I was just gonna say that because this
idea that if we can convince enough
people
is he calls it elsewhere
um the reflective state
and kind of the ground floor of merlu
Ponte is that the reflective state where
you're sitting and thinking about
thinking like he is when he's writing a
book The thinking about thinking doesn't
actually make anything happen yeah and
in large part it's the world that makes
things happen so in terms of changing
habits
I think one thing we've we've we've seen
is that it's far more likely to compel
people to act when they see like in
their lifetime conditions getting worse
whereas if conditions get worse very
slowly then the most likely outcome is
that nothing happens but the reflective
State just for
us and everyone else to remember is the
is the least likely way to change things
a little bit saying that the not to not
saying that the reflective state is you
know a form of action or anything like
that
um but you know it does depend on on our
sort of embodied being our habitual
being right because when you and the
like this is the problem also with what
sart said about dreams that there's no
freedom in dreams right
and and it's like a psychological
experiment right like if you
grew up as a dog lover say and you pet a
lot of dogs in your lifetime and then
you see a representation of a dog being
pet on a television it still activates
that sort of peripheral nervous
Connections in your own body that
recalls those so when you're sitting
there dreaming or contemplating right
you're activating these connections that
that originate and experience but you're
just doing it in a more abstract
situation it's not that reflection is is
completely sort of dis dissociated in in
Ponte from from you know making changes
in the world it's just that like yeah
it's kind of Downstream from all the
other stuff in a way
if I can adjust my formulation then uh
certainly our capacity to reflect and
whatever else you want to call it dream
meditate do nothing the reflectively
write books write philosophy books if
this all stuff happens it's very
directly
part of our comportment towards the
world
the problem is for him
political theorists have always thought
no we have to get the idea part of it
right which is in the reflective State
and that will produce an outcome whereas
he's saying that reflective State all
the stuff you're saying is true it's
still part of our embodied experience
but that doesn't produce the outcomes
that a revolutionary outcome perhaps
that start would have thought it could
have and it didn't add because like by
the time you've convinced everybody
about if class formations are in flux
like that by the time you've convinced
everybody of of something in their
concrete situations that this Theory
kind of you know points out class
formations will have shifted and it
might not be the same anymore right
that's why that's why those
representations don't work is because
they represent a world as kind of static
as opposed to this Flux Of You know this
part of the point of like EP Thompson's
the making of the working class right
class formations are always in the
process of of dissolution and formation
and negotiation right there's no static
picture to be had there that's why
representation doesn't work
if we're going to say that like you know
you're gonna do Theory and then you got
to represent the state of things and
then you gotta tell people about it so
they'll change their behavior as well
that's that's maybe the wrong route
you've you've flipped Hegel on your head
on his head okay but but you haven't
maybe you haven't flipped them on his
head enough
well the thing is though there's not
much of a route here
you said root why do you say root
and why do I say route uh I say root I
think I say both depending on the
context I think I'd probably say root
usually is that a West East thing I
don't know it's just because we said the
sentences right next to each other so I
yeah okay what is there a route to
I guess we're in the what to do with
this stage because you're not gonna get
the end point that you want insofar as
it's inundated with representation and
fantasy here this kind of then feels to
me kind of it's a fun activity but it's
kind of solipsistic and it sounds pretty
self-helpy is that
good enough or is there something more
in here
I would say it's very very basic still I
wouldn't I wouldn't say it's like a
luxury or like some kind of like
adornment on what people are I think
it's still pretty fundamental to
reference
well I think
I mean I think the upshot of this mayor
lopontian account is that
because of the world impinges on us all
this representationalism even if you're
not a philosopher like I think popular
discourse
is
saturated with representationalist
thinking I think in many ways
and I think like the value of
marilopanti is that it can show you that
that's [__] or like or that at least
it's like much less significant than you
think yeah yeah because the the choice
there is either like my the world causes
itself in me like like I'm a realist and
I see the world the way it is because it
causes him or I'm an idealist and so
that I think gives the world meaning and
makes it the way so the self-help part
is I think it can help you just chill
I think I think I think it made me feel
a lot better about stuff like when I
understood marillopontia member in my
early 20s I was like oh [__] like
just chill like just like it clarifies
things in a way it's like there's kind
of no way to get from this version of
Freedom up to something like freedom of
speech
that would just be building on top of a
a pyramid on top of an empty tomb
well that's kind of why I was trying to
say that I don't even think that freedom
is the right way
of talk like I think the language is
wrong but like you mean foreign
no no no for people when we're like
freedom of speech like a right yeah okay
you're like I think that's not even the
right language to use but I still would
say that I'm still going to be a
supporter of like not having the like
all that means to me is just something
that is totally I think consistent with
a marillopontine account when you take
the like the metaphysical baggage of
that language all it means is just like
you're not going to have the government
that rules over you like uh prescribe
the kinds of things that you can say
publicly and I think that seems like a
fine thing but it doesn't have that much
to do with freedom in like the
metaphysical sense
yeah because it's like when you when you
consider all these different things
Ponte brings up like you're an embodied
being but you're also a subject and when
you think it kind of pulls that body
behind you in a certain way and pulls it
out of view
and there's a world and there's a
society
that we live in an inter-subject and and
then there's a world yeah that we're
born of and into that pre-exists us and
that we come into it but it's also not
complete like it's open and it's it's
open for us to make meaning and out of
and assign meaning too and so when you
have these sort of four factors of body
subjectivity the social and
um and the world the the being in the
world uh like it's like okay so then how
do we thread
Freedom through that Labyrinth like it
doesn't yeah I can see why you're saying
it it the as a concept it's it's kind of
um
yeah it's it's not it's not very
concrete like if the if the con if the
abstract is what the concrete makes it
to be then then Freedom has lost a lot
of its bearings it sounds like and the
way we tend to use it and rhetorically
especially I mean maybe the way that we
could talk about it when it comes to
something like freedom of speech or like
government it's like it's not really
about Freedom necessarily as much as it
is well like government policy and laws
does change our situation to some extent
sometimes indirectly sometimes more
directly right and and I think that like
if you have a government apparatus that
is
you know has some kind of um
sense like you know Department of
censorship
I mean that that does change things
concretely in terms of like the
affordances to use the language
of your life right but that but that's
not because it's like freedom in this
metaphysical way it's just like some
other [__] it's about affordances it's
about the existential situation and I
still feel even though I I think the
mayor lopontine account is right I'm
still comfortable saying like uh I would
prefer a state of affairs where the
affordances are not a government
structure that is has a bureau of
censorship
I think the other kind of Freedom we
talked about uh earlier freedom of Labor
and freedom of consumption the freedom
of consumption
is far more dangerous to this kind of
freedom than like repressive government
apparatuses disciplining you because the
whole strategy of the supermarket was my
metaphor or you could just say tech
companies social media competing for the
attention economy I think people call it
those things are much though the freedom
to consume in that way is far more
threatening to this kind of freedom
because they are trying to
recreate the world in which you form
habits such that it is a forever
attention slot machine I'm talking about
apps and screens now and you are
habituated only to that world and it's
literally hacking your brain at the
point where this Freedom exists towards
the world in general such that their
notification Bells whistles and
endorphin rewards are the only thing
that are training your habits from now
on yeah totally and I think if there's a
little self-help bit to to merlu Ponte
here it's that you have the freedom to
not do that you have the freedom to uh
unplug and touch grass but there but the
competition there I think is almost
proving where luponti right in this
sense they want to make the world into
their app basically
your experience life world is gonna
become Twitter that's like the goal I
would say that what makes this modern
situation particularly Grim too because
you kind of set it up as a choice
between I mean not that you were
actually committing yeah
either like you know government Bureau
censorship but the reality is America
which is like even in the countries that
have a bureau right so the fact that
they're lying to everybody
like I mean it's just papers came out
like you can't get away from the
informational one unfortunately
and they kept that information secret
they would have if it didn't leak out
and then they would have continued
saying we got to send more weapons
Ukraine's gonna win everything's gonna
be great this is kind of the opposite of
what I'm saying though like over
informing you
the freedom to be over informed as we
are is more of a threat to what merlu
Ponte finds valuable in Freedom than uh
government secret paralysis through
Choice kind of thing yeah endless choice
so that you can never actually exactly
you know reflect enter your reflective
State and decide on a project for
yourself the project is always fed to
you yeah the oversaturation of
information and things to be outraged
and upset about is actually like
horrible but it works because of our
freedom yeah think about what about in
this situation because we're this is
relevant right now in Canada because uh
because uh in Ontario Healthcare is
being privatized
and so from the free perspective of a
kind of liberal Freedom that focuses on
the individual
then you're you're creating some kind of
Freedom aside apart from the you're
adding some kind of Freedom into the
medical system by by letting private
surgeons now open private practices and
perform surgeries and and decide who
their customers are and and and kind of
charge what they like although I'm sure
there'll be some kind of benchmarks for
it or something versus government
administrative health care or at least
government funded and regulated health
care which is more like what we have
um
in that case I think privatization is
going to increase the range of freedom
for medical practitioners of a certain
kind surgeons and stuff but it's going
to make a lot the rest of us a lot less
free because you're either going to have
to go to government places where the
waiting time is going to be even worse
because they're pouring resources out of
the system into private stuff or you
have to yeah cough up a shitload of
money
and which you most people probably won't
be able to afford and go to a private
surgeon have good wait times quality
care but it's going to cost an
exorbitant amount uh I think that that
from this perspective of of the social
conditions of Freedom that is the wrong
direction but yeah it's this thing where
we have to sort of hold both of those
kinds of Freedom individual freedom and
social conditions like together in a in
a way and and not you know fall into the
satrian Trap of of of kind of seeing it
only as as
radiating outwards from our existential
situation and everything out there is an
obstacle to it but we have to sort of
learn to flip that picture and and then
hold both of these contradictory
centripetal and centrifugal Notions like
somehow hold them together in in some
kind of single concept of Freedom which
is which is really really difficult to
do as
as because as evidenced by our ongoing
lack of clarity over what the [__]
Freedom really is
well good thing we solved it
yeah now we know
into an intractable problem that's what
it is
yeah well I think that's a good place
though it is I mean one more thing
Freedom then we kind of think of it as a
capacity or like a quality that humans
have and other stuff doesn't have but
this totally takes away the
human-centric-ness because it's not a
property it's not a possession
it's a condition for anyway we should
wrap up any other thoughts though
don't tempt him
oh yeah oh no I'm good anyone anyone
here anyone besides Eric
finally no
um I know I mean I think it's good
exhausted my tank on freedom yeah I mean
I I always enjoy reading marilopanti I
recommend it I think he can be a little
frustrating at first
um
but but I always find him to be like
psychologically satisfying
I think you've said that before too that
you always feel like you read them and
it's just like I feel like he's just so
right all the time that it's just like
he's so right but it's soothing it's
soothing in a narrow enough scope you
know you always want to do something
else after but if you're doing too much
if your mind's too frenetic then it's a
good uh come down it's like a medical
presentation he's so precise and
specific exactly and he's just like so
careful
um it's just great it's a pleasure to
read I don't know what Buddhism is like
but this feels Buddhist
yeah I know from my fantasies about it I
think it's about it's about relations
right the secret of freedom is not on
the side of the subject of the object
it's in between it's those it's the
relations right he he finishes by
quoting someone and the the the last
quote is really nice it's a man is but a
network of relationships and these alone
matter to him it's about our
relationships with the world with other
people like you know history is I mean
[__] history freedom is relative in
that way in that sense that it's
relational in the sense that
Freedom only obtains
within the network and the and the mesh
of these relations as they come into
being and are preserved and enacted on a
daily basis and new ones are made old
ones are are kicked off people die
people lose contact whatever
circumstances change but yeah it's the
relations that that Define freedom and
not not some simple self other binary
where where there's nothing in the
middle that you literally have an
excluded middle in most of these ways of
thinking
and to frame it we opened up talking
about that
that psych or neural experiment where
the brain acts before you're aware of
the brain acting and what's interesting
about this is that doesn't even matter
that's still yeah that's still the world
and you are the world yeah it's not an
argument saying we're not free because
of that yeah it's just another Dynamic
to take into account because what's
conditioning our brain we are free
positioning our brain and what's the
difference between a brain and a mind
and a body
there isn't one all right guys we'll
wrap it there
join our Patron all right bye yeah
hope this liberated y'all
foreign
[Music]